the Hulk is capable of much more than
many fans realize and not just in terms
of power but in depth of character the
green Goliath has a pretty complex
history one with certain tragic aspects
that are directly responsible for his
tendency to want to well
until he found cinematic success as a
member of the Avengers the Hulk's
biggest pop culture touchstone was the
live-action Incredible Hulk TV show from
the 70s on the small screen the man
monster was nowhere near as powerful as
the comic book or movie versions so
there's one aspect of the Hulk that
might come as a surprise he's always
been hard to beat but it turns out that
even if he loses a fight he'll be back
it's not that he won't die it's that he
can't
The Hulk possesses a healing factor that
makes Deadpool's look like a band-aid he
survived every kind of death you can
imagine from getting used as a
pincushion by Wolverine to even having
Bruce banners body dissected and put
into jars in 2002's Incredible Hulk the
end it takes Hulk less than 20 minutes
for his body to regenerate after being
devoured by mutated cockroaches which is
pretty handy when you're living in a
world with you know mutated cockroaches
in 2005's Incredible Hulk number 77 we
learned that his body has evolved to the
point where he can safely extract oxygen
from water allowing him to stay
underwater as long as he wants and he
can even survive in the vacuum of space
for a pretty long time it was in 2018 s
Avengers number 680 pour that we learned
that even death can't stop the Hulk
plenty of heroes have come back from the
dead but most of them wait a while the
new immortal Hulk series on the other
hand has shown us that even if you can
kill him he'll just come back as soon as
night falls and he'll be angry while his
alter ego might be a brilliant scientist
the Hulk isn't exactly known for his
intelligence that doesn't mean that he's
always stupid though for one thing there
are so many versions of the character
and some of them are literal rocket
scientists in his origin story the very
first version of the Hulk isn't going to
win jeopardy any time soon but he can
speak in full sentences that aren't just
about smashing the gray Hulk is clever
and crafty out thinking his foes as
often as he overpowers them then there's
the merged Professor ball who shares
banners genius the doc green Hulk that
we saw in 2014 and even the evil
mastermind called the maestro who
originates in a dystopian future on the
other hand even the supposedly less
intelligent versions of the character
sometimes only seems stupid because we
can't see through their eyes for example
in 2012 indestructible Hulk series
writer Mark Waid hardly bothered giving
the Hulk any dialogue at all
but not because of a lack of smarts this
Hulk is more like a force of nature a
creature of action completely beyond
words if you're a giant green Titan who
can take on all comers and an outerspace
gladiatorial arena what do you have to
say to anyone besides you know somebody
please get me a new pair of pants it's
easy to go back to those early stories
and think that the Hulk was a brand-new
kind of character whose stories
captivated an audience that had never
seen anything like him the truth however
is that Bruce Banner was not the first
Hulk in the pages of Marvel Comics in
fact he wasn't even the second or the
third
Hulk version one was a giant robot in
1960 strange tales number 75 next came
xemnu the living hulk a giant furry
alien who could control the minds of
multiple humans at once later after the
more incredible hulk became a marvel
superhero xemnu went through a name
change and started being billed as the
Living Titan in his very rare
appearances which usually involved
getting beaten up by the Incredible Hulk
the final Hulk to precede the one we all
know in love was a sea monster in 1961 s
tales to astonish number 21 find out see
the Hulk of the silent screen is a
character in a movie the story fools you
into thinking you're looking at an
audience watching a movie called The
Hulk when the sea monster steps out of
the movie screen you learn at different
audiences watching a movie about another
audience being scared by a sea monster
who emerges from the film but it doesn't
end there you eventually learn you the
audience of the comic are watching an
audience that is watching another
audience who is watching still another
audience with the final audience being
the ones freaking out about the sea
monster that's astonishing all rights
but maybe not in the way they thought
when the hope first smashed his way into
the panel's of Marvel Comics in 1962 his
skin was gray instead of the
now-familiar green something that
changed in the second issue the
Stanly chose gray over the suggestions
of colorist stan goldberg who argued
gray was too difficult to keep a
consistent shade Lee wasn't convinced
until hope number 1 was released then he
saw what Goldberg was talking about in
the mid 80s once coloring technology had
gotten a whole lot better the gray Hulk
got a new lease on life writer artist Al
Milgram resurrected this version in 1986
is Incredible Hulk number 324 when Peter
David took over writing the title he ran
with it and the grey crafty Hulk
revitalized the series in that classic
storyline the Hulk began working as an
enforcer for casino owner and mobster in
Las Vegas giving this version his own
unique name Joe fix it in 2008 the Hulk
title was rebooted with a malevolent Red
Hulk who was eventually revealed to be
banners longtime enemy army general
Thunderbolt Ross another military man
Robert maverick later assumes the title
and powers of the Red Hulk sporting an
incredible gamma-powered mustache and
mirror shades until the immortal Hulk
drains the gamma radiation out of him in
Avengers number 685 the red Hulk's
aren't the only different versions of
the gamma-powered goliath running around
the Marvel Universe while Bruce banners
dark side will always be at the center
of the story there's been a whole roster
of Hulk's running around at one time or
another
the first was banners cousin Jen Walters
better known as she-hulk
who got her powers from a blood
transfusion banners wife betty was the
red she-hulk for time and there's even a
third she-hulk named Lyra who comes from
a dystopian reality where men and women
are in a constant state of war
technically speaking she's Bruce banners
daughter
there's also Braun aka Amadeus Cho who
used to be known as the totally awesome
Hulk and then there's a son of Hulk and
another son of Hulk and the Hulk's
original sidekick Rick Jones was once
the blue scaled a bomb
he was eventually cured by doc Greene
before being executed in the pages of
secret Empire but compared to the rest
of Rick's life that wasn't all that
unusual he was once the new Bucky for a
hot minutes and used to be half of
Captain Marvel - we all know the rule
about the Hulk don't get Bruce Banner
angry and you won't have
worry about the other guy right that's
my secret captain amazing
not quite back in the early days he
worked more like a werewolf emerging
from Banner at night and only at night
in the late 80s writer Peter David
stressed that Hulk was more than just a
manifestation of banners rage he
represented banners survival instinct
and David's finale on the title 1988 s
Incredible Hulk number 467 been our
attempts to end his own life several
times in the wake of his wife's death
including a swan dive off the Empire
State Building and the Hulk shows up to
save him every time you don't have to
read comics to be familiar with this
particular idea in The Avengers movie
Bruce Banner confesses to the team that
he attempted to do the same thing but
was stopped by his other self so you're
saying that the Hulk the other guy saved
my life that's nice a Ewing writer of
immortal Hulk brought back the day-night
dynamic more recently and added a brand
new trigger for the transformation death
Bruce Banner can only die during the day
but rises again as the Hulk once the Sun
Goes Down the night is his time when it
comes to the question of how strong the
Hulk is there's no definitive answer
even after he transforms the Hulk's
strength continues to increase and the
angrier he gets the stronger he gets as
long as he's on his feet and he's
fighting there's virtually no limit to
his power
welcome strongest Avenger Oh what this
is why the wilder versions of the Hulk
tend to do more damage when the green
guy has a degree of banners intelligence
he isn't always willing to let himself
get angry but when the Hulk doesn't have
banner holding him back he becomes a
massively destructive force ironically
though one of his more memorable feats
of strength came when banner was in
control in the pages of secret Wars he
holds up a mountain range on his back
saving most of Marvel's heroes from
being crushed the trick it happens
because of Reed Richards who keeps
insulting Hulk in order to keep him
strong enough while the heroes find a
way to escape he's a founding member of
the Avengers on both the comics page and
the silver screen a part of the original
lineup of the defenders and he even
spent some time in a strange lineup
called the new Fantastic Four with all
that in his his
it seems like the Hulk is a good
teammate to have around when the bad
guys come calling
well while you definitely do not want to
be on the side fighting against them the
truth is that the Hulk just does not
play well with other superheroes you
will when the Avengers one of the team
one of one of our friends is what
friends do they support each other
you're a Berners friend his friend for
you he'll help them but the Alliance is
always an uneasy one inspite of helping
to found the Avengers for example he
quit the team in the second issue and
has fought the team more often than he's
been on it the Hulk's contempt for other
superheroes is pretty obvious even when
one of his more intelligent personas is
in charge
for example the professor Hulk had the
reins during the original Infinity
Gauntlet storyline this version of the
giant is known for his intelligence and
relative calm but he still spends his
entire time with the assembled heroes
insulting them and even does some
ill-advised trash talking against Thanos
whether he's green or grey whether he
talks like a caveman or like a Nobel
Prize candidate you can be sure of one
thing about the Hulk
whoever you are he probably doesn't like
you there are plenty of different
interpretations of the Hulk but one of
the biggest changes to happen over the
years is the way his origin story has
developed the gamma bomb is always a big
part of it the catalyst for releasing
the monster inside Bruce Banner but ever
since we learned about Bruce's tortured
childhood in Incredible Hulk number 312
there has been a completely different
layer to their relationship the Hulk was
with Bruce Banner long before he was
exposed to the radiation that gave him a
form the gamma bomb just opened the door
for something that had been inside
banner since he was a boy in 1991 s
Incredible Hulk number 377 Bruce Banner
is officially diagnosed with multiple
personality disorder for the first time
according to doc Samson the Marvel
Universe's resident super psychiatrist
both the gray and green Hulk's are
splintered personalities that banners
subconscious created to protect him from
the trauma he suffered growing up ever
since that comic more personalities have
emerged including a huge malevolent
version called the devil Hulk it's this
last one who appears to be ruling the
roost and the horror themed pages of
immortal
during Planet Holt the story a big chunk
of thor ragnarok was based on writer
Greg pock presented an interesting take
on Hulk's view of banner as the Hulk's
new gladiator allies tell their life
stories to each other
The Hulk shares his own when he tells
them of the gamma bomb that set him
loose from banner he not only says the
bomb didn't create him he claims banner
made the bomb to kill him check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]